I always said from the time I could talk
that I was going to be a doctor my
father was a surgeon in Jacksonville
Florida he unfortunately died when I was
still a toddler and I had determined at
a very early age that I was going to be
a doctor but I experiences an
african-american didn't begin when I
went to college it was a more prominent
issue because I was recruited to Vassar
when they wanted to have an
african-american student so that clearly
it was an issue they students in fact
came down ahead of time
before it was agreed that I was going to
go because I had to agree and a school
had to agree and now it turns out these
students had to agree because they
wanted to be sure that if I can mix my
metaphors the first man got on base Yale
Medical School was was it was a
different story because one of my best
friends was also accepted she not only
was my basser friend and became my
anatomy partner and it so I was a little
squeamish about having who I had as an
Anatomy partner I was glad to have my
friends from Vassar but she also kind of
gave me a home away from home because
her father was the master of one of the
Yale colleges and so I went over and had
afternoon tea and this and that and so
was it was that was a much easier
transition than I would have expected it
wasn't a big deal being an
african-american at
in the first place nobody was much
interested it was very challenging was
also wartime and there were other things
on their minds but on the other hand it
may be that there was something about me
that was different because I had the
experience at Vassar of being totally
accepted really had lots of friends was
well liked and and I I have a little
expression anything that has happened is
possible and so they forgot about it and
if you're nervous and edgy about it
they're gonna be edgy about it so that
was there and it was worked out
absolutely perfectly and that opened up
a whole new chapter in my life which was
the meeting the romance and the marrying
of David Hamburg and we have now been
married over 60 years I believe it is
and I think it's going to work out it
seems really good it wasn't a very big
deal to be an african-american at Yale
but it was much more of a challenge to
be a woman there in medical school oh I
didn't notice this advanced cuz it was
all women but in medical school
a woman would when a question was tossed
out would answer it and it would be as
if talking into the wind hadn't happened
later on a man would say the same thing
the same thing and they say God John
that was so fabulous that's really
important blah blah blah and so I had
it's minor if you will crusade to help
women to just hold their own just to be
an equal in the classroom people are
always interested in my responses as in
Africa
American fact is my responses are not as
an african-american there are as Betty
Hamburg I don't go around all the time
you know thinking well now how do I feel
about this as an african-american I
don't anymore than I ask myself how do I
feel about that as having lived in New
York and being a New Yorker I mean it's
just is there but it's not determinative
it's not a litmus for people it's you
know it's just there Yale School of
Medicine was something that really
changed my whole life because it taught
me to be I think the technical word is
an autodidact that means that you are
your own teacher and so I learned how to
learn and there's one of the most
critical aspects I think of the
experience there of course I was
learning medicine at that point but
everything I've learned from that point
onward has always been heavily tinged
with my taking a responsibility for
finding out what I need to know and then
how to learn it and then applying myself
to acquiring the necessary knowledge and
for Yale I and I'm very grateful to Yale
for that
you